the jurogan experience luckily i'm
staying with my friends out here and
they
super healthy so that's felt good but
right after this i'm going
to see toria who do you know out here my
friend julia and jake
they're super sweet it's funny because i
met julia through my patreon
she was like you know follow me on
patreon and i didn't know you had a
patreon
yeah i have a i have a small information
no patreon is the closest
i'll get patreon is the closest i'll get
how many gals have turned to only fans
during the pandemic
so many quite a few i thought about it a
couple times i was like do i how do i
suck how does that work though because
like
someone can always they save those
pictures i know that's why i would never
do it yeah
if it was like top secret and you know
just between
yeah here you go don't tell anyone shh
yeah it's a weird thing right because
and also my i'm i'm too
sensitive if i like posted oh i have an
only fans now and like two people joined
one of them being my mom because she's
supportive i'd be like this
hurts i know this lady that started and
only fans i think i don't know if she
was doing it for money or just desperate
or just wanted
just wanted to do it i don't know but uh
she got all this hate it was really
interesting to see
and uh even from her own family like
people furious at her
for showing her tits that's crazy yeah
if you have good tits and you don't mind
showing them
yeah it's a weird thing like why why is
everybody mad it's one thing it's if
like you're
if your wife starts showing her [ __ ]
you're like hey
that's mine yeah i have a ring saying
hey
that's our that's our [ __ ] cut it out
yeah
but if you're it's your sister or
something like that like
i don't think you're allowed to say
anything you can't get mad at her
you know like i don't understand the
getting mad part what are you mad at
yeah i don't i think it's a great way
for people to make money if they can
it's
saturated so it's hard you have to
really like hustle like that becomes
your business this girl who works for
brendan's job makes like a hundred
thousand dollars a month showing her
feet
yeah i i need a really
there's no more like uh hey she's doing
playboy
did you hear she's doing playboy you
know is there playboy anymore
there's not even an option for it so
maybe like there's playboy but they're
like mostly doing articles and like
nice photo shoots there's not really
much they used to be a big thing they'd
like make a big huge offer you know and
then like someone you know
right like a famous person would show
their tits yeah
yeah yeah i remember that like didn't
demi moore do it
and yeah and a bunch of like kim
kardashian yeah like
actresses and famous people like if
playboy was classy mm-hmm
like oh she's in playboy it was a big
deal
a big a famous girl in wrestling did it
sable when i was younger
she's married to black brock lesnar huge
like that's a huge deal
huge that was like you know yeah now
she's just the only fans that make
yeah it's really quick well that's the
thing is these gals are made like that
bad barbie girl that baby
whatever it is oh how do i say it ba had
baby
is it baby it's not bad barbie no bad
baby she spells it with an age after
they catch me outside
girl catch me outside how about that how
about that that girl
made a million dollars in six hours she
claims that's right i've heard
what she's claiming a liar it sounds
like some people are very cynical about
it like she's claiming she made that but
like
a lot of other girls who are on there
will show their their receipts
yeah like here it says i'm the top 1.001
that's weird too showing your receipts
like i would feel like if you did that
people would stop giving you money
i know you have to be like i'm not
making too much
it's a small it's a small group
maybe they want to contribute to it
because it's exciting because your girl
is number one
right like maybe there's like rooting
for a team in the nfl
you're like go bad baby yeah if you only
got to give her 10 bucks a month or
whatever it is
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience